j'accueille maintenant mohamed sifaoui
bonsoir m'hamed titawi vous êtes
journaliste en presse écrite en
télévision vous avez aussi publié des
livres la france malade de l'islamisme
mes frères assassins comme angers
infiltrer une cellule d'al qaïda est
aujourd'hui toujours aux éditions du
cherche midi sur les traces de ben laden
le jeu trouble des américains
la question est simple c'est où est donc
passée oussama ben laden alors d'abord
on nous a dit que ben laden se cachait
dans ses fameuses grottes de tora bora
alors à la télévision sur lci on voyait
des coupes comme ça de la montagne avec
un intérêt tout était creux il y avait
des escaliers et des ascenseurs enfin
c'était super oui en fait à ressembler à
un peu au docteur no dont on les voyait
on les voyait sur lci mais c'était pas
des images de m6 étaient les images
préparé par des propagandistes de du
pentagon moins que les téléphones les
télés françaises en a une a envoyé un
sommet des espèces de bunker comme salle
ultra sophistiquée avec des armatures
qui empêchait les bombes les bombes de
pénétrer on est en effet on est allé là
bas je dirais oui alors ben je suis allé
avec un collègue
est ce qu'on a vu sur place n'a
absolument rien à voir mais attention
rien à voir d'ailleurs j'ai dans le
livre j'ai mis quelques photos livres
pour illustrer un petit peu ce qu'on a
vu ce sont des des grottes tout à fait
tout à fait simple et parfois ou traouc
creusé par la main de l'homme ou
naturels sains mais qu'ils n'avaient
absolument rien d'extraordinaire en tout
cas c'était très loin de ce que les
américains nous décrivez ces espèces de
bon coeur avec intérêt et une couche de
béton et que seuls d'aider des missiles
spécialement conçus pouvaient pouvait
perforé c'était tout à fait loin de tous
donc première chose il n'était pas là
n'en va en tous les cas ce n'était pas
capable de le protéger ensuite toujours
pour le capturer il ya eu la fameuse
opération anaconda qui devenu ensuite
l'opération condor et vous dites dans
votre bouquin qu'on a surtout tuer des
civils en fait oui il ya eu il ya eu des
dérapages des dérives assez grave de la
part de l'armée américaine en
afghanistan et est donc ce que j'ai pu
je veux dire constaté sur place et j'ai
pas été le seul
c'est qu'il y avait il ya aujourd'hui un
rejet total de la base afghane par
rapport à tout ce qui tout ce que les
américains nous raconte démocratie tout
ça pour eux un sont des mots qui ne
veulent absolument rien dire pour eux la
démocratie la vivent
ils ont une certaine forme de démocratie
c'est ce qu'ils appellent la noyade
jirga c'est à dire une réunion entre les
chefs de tribu qui d'une manière ou
d'une autre
autour d'un débat autour d'une tasse de
thé décide de l'avenir de tel ou de tel
autre tribu alors la thèse principale de
votre bouquin mohamed sifaoui son fini
par se demander
dites vous si les américains ne font pas
exprès de ne pas attraper ben laden et
garde pas son arrestation pour les
élections présidentielle américaine en
novembre 2004 pour vous dire vrai je
crois qu'on a eu déjà l'occasion d'en
parler ici je suis pas un partisan de la
thèse du complot il faut il faut il faut
préciser jeu j'ai bien délimiter la
responsabilité des islamistes et depuis
déjà plusieurs années
néanmoins il y a des choses qui me
posent à me poser un certain nombre de
questions et je prendrai deux cas en
particulier la première l'arrestation de
ramzi ben al shaiba celui qui devait
être le 20e pirate de l'air du 11
septembre qui a été arrêtée curieusement
le 11 septembre 2002 c'est à dire une
année jour pour jour après les attentats
de new york et de washington
vous savez je ne crois pas vraiment
qu'il existe de hasards et de
coïncidences en politique et en
jouissent géostratégie deuxième fait si
l arrestation de khalid cheikh mohammed
se considérait comme le numéro 3 d'al
qaïda
il a été arrêté le 1er mars 2003 à
quelques jours d'un vote qui devait
disons une d'une résolution de la guerre
en irak et trois semaines avant le début
des hostilités en irak c'est c'était
aussi un moment où
george bush avait besoin du soutien de
son opinion que je voulais dire c'est
donc ça veut dire que ces deux personnes
ont été arrêtées à des moments
stratégiques
donc ce que vous supposez d'une certaine
façon c'est que les américains savaient
où ils étaient isolés logique comme on
dit dans la police est en fait ils ont
attendu la date utile pourrait les
arrêter pour moi en ce qui concerne ces
deux ces deux fois que sont celui de
samedi l'arrestation s'agit donc de
randy benchaiba et et de khaled cheikh
mohammed
ils ont ils ont attendu le moment voulu
pour pour agir c'est c'est ça rentre
dans le cadre de calculs praticiens
extrêmement étroits alors étriqué mais
dangereux sur au niveau des calculs donc
évidemment on peut penser qu'ils savent
où est ben laden mais qu'ils attendront
les élections américaines pour l'arrêter
et en tous les cas une chose que vous
dites dans votre bouquin c'est que ne
pouvait pas l'arrêter avant
l'intervention en irak
puisque la plupart des américains du
peuple américain sont convaincus que les
gens qui ont fait les attentats du 11
septembre reuters center sont des
irakiens qu'elles n'ont pas compris la
différence il pense que c'est lié
donc si on arrêtait ben laden avant
d'intervenir en irak c'était saugrenue
et du point de vue américain
moi je pense qu'effectivement la
population l'opinion américaine a été
extrêmement manipulé dans cette histoire
et george w bush avait besoin du soutien
de cette opinion publique et donc
l'arrestation d'oussama ben laden aurait
dix ont suscité dans l'esprit où le
subconscient collectif la victoire sur
le terrorisme et ils ont joué sur une
sorte d' amalgame autour du 11 septembre
sur oussama ben laden le régime irakien
vous vous rappelez ces histoires de deux
rencontres soit 10 entre services
secrets irakiens oussama ben laden ou
mohammed atta le chef du commando ainsi
de suite ils nous ont nous ont raconté
pas mal d'histoires à ce sujet et c'est
pas moi qui le dit ce sont des sondages
réalisés aux états unis quelques jours
avant le début de la guerre en irak
un américain sur deux tenez vous bien
croyez que les 19 pirates du ans après
tous irakien c'est à dire qu'il y avait
un travail de fond quand même de
manipulation pour faire croire à cette
opinion publique que le danger en
réalité venaient d'irak et qu'il fallait
donc punir ce régime qui est qui qui est
un régime dictatorial forcément on le
sait dans l'éducation c'est comme ça il
n'y a pas que dans les médias ses mains
nous avons clé les américains sur les
sauveurs du monde et ils sont étonnés
que quand chrétiens des problèmes ya des
gens qui se retourne contre eux ils
pensent qu'ils sauvent l'afrique mais
moi je marche avec deux trois américains
où ils sont stupéfaits de la réaction
qu'il peut y avoir à leur encontre ils
sont pas conscients qu'en du truc alors
quand on vous dit mais il est peut-être
mort ben laden c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'ils n'ont pas arrêté vous dit non
parce que s'il était mort il en aurait
fait un martyr évidemment c'est à dire
qu'ils auraient montré ses funérailles
évidemment écoutez ça fait deux semaines
à peu près à une information qui est
passée totalement inaperçue
le chef de la légion arabe en
tchétchénie a été tuée dans des
conditions que l'on ignore aujourd'hui
le jour de sa mort cette information a
été rendue publique par ses propres
compagnons le jour où le commandant fera
table près le prédécesseur de ce chef de
la légion arabe en tchétchénie a été
tuée
sa mort a été filmée rendu public et son
enterrement a été filmée mon dieu public
dans des sites par des sites islamistes
pourquoi pour les islamistes c'est très
important de rendre public ce genre de
demande
la mort du chef le martyre le symbole
qui va non pas affaiblir les trous guen
au contraire parce qu'on n'est pas dans
une culture occidentale ou
il ya une stratégie faut cacher ce
système d'information parce que ça
risque d'être préjudiciable au contraire
dans leur honneur et leur idéologie
il faut rendre public ce genre
d'informations parce que ça galvanise
baisse que de malheur le malheur et
moteur quoi absolument pour eux le
malheur et moteur d'une brune voyez par
exemple après l'assassinât du cheikh
yassine en palestine comment ils sortent
ils crient et crient vengeance
il essaie de passer à l'acte ce n'est
pas du bluff les islamistes ne bluffe
pas quand ils peuvent ils
il tente de passer à la donc ben laden
pas mort ben laden je ne crois pas
qu'ils soient alors où est il et vous
dites il est au waziristan voilà alors
ça le waziristan je connaissais le
pakistan l'afghanistan les zones
tribales entre l'afghanistan et le
pakistan qui sont des zones non
contrôlées dix ans mais le waziristan
c'est au waziristan c'est une région
tribale qui se situe entre le pakistan
et l'afghanistan
c'est dans les zones tribales c'est dans
l'es6 chez une des antennes des one cela
il ya sept ans tribales qui qui sont
peuplés par ce qu'on appelle les
pachtouns enfin donc une ethnie qui à la
fois parfois côté pakistanais parfois
côté afghan et le waziristan est une est
une région qui est particulière parce
que c'est c'est la région où l'idéologie
islamiste est la mieux ancrer j'allais
dire où les où les gens sont très
influencés est très très proche de cette
idéologie
oussama ben laden est considéré comme un
demi dieu et vous que j'étais allée
waziristan on est allé aux portes du
waziristan c'est à dire que lorsqu'on a
voulu aller comme par hasard
habituellement les uns tribal toutes les
zones tribales sont fermés aux étrangers
principalement aux journalistes
quand on a voulu aller je suis parti
comme ça faire un peu le naïf auprès
d'une autorité locale de leurs les
représentants du ministère de
l'intérieur pakistanais à peshawar et je
leur ai dit je veux aller dans une dans
les zones tribales
ils m'ont dit a pas de problème allez
allez j et vous voulez aller où
exactement j'ai dit au waziristan ils
m'ont dit non pouvait aller partout sauf
au waziristan quand j'ai dit pourquoi le
responsable qui m'a répondu m'a dit non
parce qu'il ya un conflit entre deux
tribus ça serait dangereux pour vous
liban écoutez je vous cite ce que vous
voulez une décharge je prends mes
responsabilités je suis un adulte je
suis jeune et je veux y aller et en fait
j'ai insisté il voulait absolument rien
savoir et à ce moment là je les ai un
peu provoc et j'ai dit pourquoi il ya
oussama ben laden qui se cache là bas et
là il m'a foutu dehors donc bon c'est un
indice parmi d'autres mais disons que
j'ai une certaine rigueur qui ne me
permet pas de tirer des conclusions à la
suite de d'un tel incident il est banal
alors on a pris la décision avec mon
collègue manolo d'arthuys de de nous
rendre avec nous deux guides aux azéris
temps donc on a passé plusieurs barrages
on est arrivé au port du waziristan et
la la la la route nous a été carrément
barré 10 km de miranshah donc vous
pensez que c'est là où il se cache
écoutez c'est là où sa présence nous a
été signalé par plusieurs sources
j'ai discuté avec un colonel des
services secrets pakistanais avec des
islamistes avec des responsables de deux
écoles coraniques et dans plusieurs
plusieurs régions du pakistan et toutes
les informations corroborées toutes les
informations recoupées que la présence
d'oussama ben laden pouvait plus ou
moins être disons on pouvait le dire
avec une quasi certitude au waziristan
et à miranshah plus précise les rangs de
chasse entre non c'est juste dans le 9-3
de miranshah donc dont peine bon goût à
ce moment là vous êtes obligés de
rebrousser chemin que vous arrivez à 10
km de miranshah
obligés de rebrousser chemin nous a
empêchés d'aller plus loin un
alors bon
on est rentrés nous mon enquête sur
place s'est terminée au mois d'août on
est rentrés donc quelques jours plus
tard et trois semaines trois semaines
après la fin de notre présence au
pakistan il ya un fait qui m'a conforté
dans mes convictions
c'est qu'il ya une opération qui a eu
lieu à l'endroit même où on nous avait
une opération des américains des
pakistanais qui ont tué une dizaine de
membres d'al qaïda ça c'est un premier
fait le deuxième fait le 11 septembre
2003 souvenez-vous sama ben laden la
carotte du public une cassette où vous
le voyez gras dans la montagne à à côté
d'eux à ayman zawahiri le numéro deux de
l'organisation terroriste
et là c'est pas que je sois un expert en
topographie ou en quoi que ce soit mais
les l'endroit me rappeler un petit peu
ce que j'avais vu au waziristan et donc
j'ai appelé des sources pakistanaises
qui m'ont confirmé que c'était bien au
waziristan sur ce point les autorités
pakistanaises sont restées muettes
jusqu'au mois de décembre où ils ont
avoué eux-mêmes que les claques à sète
qui a été rendu public non seulement un
demi tour 2003 a été bel et bien tard et
aux loisirs en fête ce que vous dites
vous c'est qu'il est au waziristan bien
au chaud en attendant les élections
américaines
moi je dis qu'il a été en serre qui
l'encerclé aujourd'hui comment je peux
le dire j'ai travaillé sur la base d'une
carte géographique sur la base
d'informations avéré la présence de
forces spéciales américaines et
pakistanaises dans des villages dans des
régions bien précises à la fois côté
argol côté pakistanais
sur la base de cette carte géographique
j'ai tracé en fait j'ai coché je
m'aperçois qu'il ya en fait un cercle
chose qui ressort ou sam à ben laden et
pour moi aujourd'hui encerclée depuis
près d'une année et donc tous et tous
ces gestes sans contrôle et il ne peut
pas bouger énormément et je vais vous
dire une chose ça je vais le dire ici
parce que je n'ai pas dit ailleurs mais
je vais le dire ici il ya ça fait un
mois à peu près j'ai été contacté à ma
grande surprise par quelqu'un qui
qui est dans l'équipe de campagne de
john kerry ouais il m'a fait savoir que
john kerry ou du moins son entourage
avaient les mêmes informations qu'ils
étaient en train de contacter tous ceux
qui avaient enquêté sur cette affaire à
travers le monde pour recueillir le
maximum d'informations et révélé cette
affaire à l'opinion publique américaine
parce que ça serait très grave si moi je
ne dis pas que c'est vrai à 100% mais je
dis que j'ai beaucoup de doutes
1 j'ai beaucoup de doutes et des doutes
qui sont confirmées et conforter de joe
jour après jour donc si john kerry
s'intéresse à cette histoire c'est que
c'est sérieux
voici ses sérieux il faut que ça sorte
oui et si si et si ça sort il faut de ce
une manière pour diverses raisons pas
pour ça mais honnêtement il faut que de
george bush ne soit pas rue oui c'est ça
je suis pas américain ce qu'est ce qui
vous inquiète en fait ce qui nous
inquiète c'est parti pour le bien de
cette planète
il y avait je le dis à la fin de mon
livre je sais il ya oussama ben laden ça
serait bien qu'ils disparaissent ya
georges bush ça serait bien qu'il soit
par une deuxième fille ariane sharon
aussi il faut pas qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient réélus c'est à dire que on est
face à des gens qui sont en train de
jouer avec l'avenir de la planète
donc il appartient dans les démocraties
comme c'est le cas aux états unis
à chaque électeur américain de prendre
la décision en son âme et conscience que
vous dites oh ben mohamed sifaoui c'est
qu'il faut pas laisser à george bush la
possibilité d'être réélu en sortant de
son chapeau au dernier moment à quinze
jours des élections
déjà le principe c'est à dire qu'il
s'est moqué de la planète entière
il est en train de se passer moi
l'expression se foutent de notre gueule
à tous d'une part mais d'autre part
idiot logiquement c'est lui et son
équipe ce sont des gens dangereux
il véhicule une idéologie fasciste je
suis désolé ce sont des intégristes
alors je ne peux pas en tant que
musulman dénoncer les musulmans
intégristes et laisser de côté les
intégristes juifs ou chrétiens
je suis désolé il faut aujourd'hui il ya
une montée des extrémismes partout il ya
un retour acharné vers leur la religion
il appartient à tout le monde de
dénoncer ces fascistes c'est une autre
forme de fascisme
il faut les dénoncer ces gens là tous
commis sont je mettrai pas naturellement
sur un pied d'égalité george bush
oussama ben laden parce que ce sont deux
fasciste différents mais toutes
proportions gardées il reste que ce sont
quand même de fascistes vous n'êtes que
je vous êtes d'accord avec cette idée
est ce que vous pensez que c'est
plausible cette idée que finalement les
américains saurai où et oussama ben
laden et qu'ils le gardent en réserve
pour les élections au fait moi je pense
qu'effectivement ils doivent savoir dans
quelle région se trouve ben laden mais
entre savoir où il est allé le chercher
il ya un grand pas et en plus les
américains ils sont pas beaux sur ce
genre de terrain l'a d'ailleurs quand il
ya eu l'opération musée la dernière fois
soi-disant est venu méreau deux d'al
qaïda ils sont cassés les dents ils
n'ont pas attrapé il m'a attrapée dit
malheureux et dynamise terroristes et
l'autre il sait tirer ils savent pas
c'est comme en afrique ou en somalie en
somalie oui ils sont pas prêts pour ça
les américains ils arrivent avec la
grosse artillerie bombardent tout le
monde il expose tout c'est fini donc là
je pense qu'effectivement il
ils savent dans quelle région se trouve
ben laden il peut pas aller chercher ou
penser ça vous pensez que waziristan au
vietnam ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
irak
ils sont complètement débordés non mais
vous pensez qu'ils peuvent pas aller le
chercher au waziristan où je pense que
ça m'a bel laden
s'il est arrêté d'abord ce sera une
opération des forces spéciales de il y
aura un conflit complicités à
l'intérieur même des zones tribales
donc je pense qu'ils seront assez malin
pour composer avec les deux éléments
c'est à dire une une complicité à
l'intérieur même des zones tribales qui
va leur faciliter l'accès à une
opération des forces spéciales
ceci étant vous dites que la
neutralisation d'oussama ben laden
n'amènera évidemment pas et
malheureusement pas la fin du terrorisme
vous dites que c'est une idéologie
fasciste criminels racistes xénophobes
antisémites
un combat comme l'idéologie nazie et tac
je pense qu'il qu'il appartient aux
musulmans d'abord et aux non musulmans
chiites parce que c'est le combat tout
le monde d'éviter ces pièges dans
lesquels on essaye de nous faire tomber
tous c'est cette notion de guerre de
civilisation de guerre de religion il
n'existe pas de guerres de religion ce
qu'il existe aujourd'hui c'est une
guerre parce qu'elle est là il faut
l'avoir eux le savent c'est à dire les
islamistes savent qu'il ya une guerre
nous en ligne hors encours gérés le
jihad planétaire
le ter est bel et bien là il faut
aujourd'hui qu'on sache que sensio n'est
pas une guerre qui oppose des musulmans
et non musulmans mais à des fascistes
des fascistes à des gens qui rejette et
qui condamne le fascisme surtout pas
faire un amalgame entre l'islamisme et
les musulmans il est sûr c'est surtout
le problème c'est qu'on entend peu de
voix comme la vôtre mohamed sifaoui
c'est vrai que souvent les musulmans en
interviennent pas dans le débat public
pour marquer leur différence savez je
suis pas je suis pas vraiment d'accord
parce qu'on en fait c'est pas ça si je
suis là aujourd'hui c'est parce que vous
m'avez invité
donc il ya beaucoup de musulmans qui
dénoncent ce fascisme et qui ne sont
invités nulle part on leur donne pas la
parole donc naturellement connaissant la
puissance des médias si on leur donne
pas la parole aux musulmans
naturellement personne ne le saura moi
je vais vous dire une chose si vous
permettez je suis et je vais si vous me
le permettez sauté sur l'occasion de ma
présence ici pour dire que je veux
lancer un appel à tous les musulmans de
france pour organiser une marche pour
dénoncer l'islamisme et le terrorisme et
je dis bien l'islamisme les tories c'est
une c'est une c'est un appel qui est
lancé aux musulmans mais aussi à tous
les non musulmans qui adhèrent à ce
combat et qui adhèrent à l'idée que
effectivement la guerre en irak a été
une erreur qui alimente le terrorisme
que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au
proche orient est une gravissime erreur
qui alimente le terrorisme islamiste
tous ceux qui adhèrent à ces idées et
ben je les invite à m'écrire à marianne
parce que marianne le journal marianne
et jean françois kahn que vous receviez
la semaine dernière ici même et d'accor
est partie prenante dans cette danse est
dans cette initiative est donc je suis
en train de préparer d'essayer de
contacter des associations de musulmans
et de non musulmans pour que justement
la voix des musulmans soient visibles et
qu'on voit en france que beaucoup de
musulmans dénoncent ce fascisme qu'est
l'islamisme et qui tente à et qu'il qui
feront tout pour se démarquer de cette
idéologie et donc nous avons déjà
d'ailleurs dans cette
dans cette veine
avec avec des amis décidé d'organiser
une rencontre internationale au mois de
novembre contre ce que j'appelle pour 1
eur nuremberg contre le fascisme
islamiste et nous avons 300 signatures
dans les 300 signatures un tiers les
profs dans les 300 premiers signataires
signataires un tiers sont musulmans donc
si vous dire que c'est vrai que nous
sommes quelques-uns à être visible dans
cette dénonciation de du terrorisme et
de l'intégrisme mais c'est pas parce que
nous sommes quelques-uns indivisible que
nous sommes uniquement quelques uns sont
beaucoup plus nombreuses
vous avez pas peur pour vous non non
j'ai peur pour tout le monde parce que
le terrorisme ne vise pas moi il vise
tout le monde aveuglement est ce que le
fait de ce terme mais forcément à l'abri
d'un acte terroriste ce qui était dans
les trains de madrid n'avait pas écrit
de livre pour dénoncer le carreau mais
malheureusement donc je ne pense pas
qu'il faille penser en ces termes
moi je ne réfléchis pas à tout ça pour
moi et je le dis et je le répète ils
n'arriveront jamais à terroriser
c'est plus fort que moi mais ils
n'arriveront jamais à intérioriser parce
que d'abord il frappe lâchement et ce ne
sont pas des lâches qui vont me faire
peur et d'autre part ils sont dans une
hymne dans un monde parallèle
ils sont dans une espèce de paranoïa
collective qui qui qui les emmène vers
vers des actes extrêmement grave
et moi je les dénonce c'est aussi simple
que ça vous êtes protégé quand même oui
je suis protégé mais mais vous savez je
suis croyant aussi je suis croyant et je
pense que là la mort de chacun d'entre
nous est écrite quelque part et quand ça
doit arriver ça arrivera par une maladie
par un accident de voiture par un arrêt
cardiaque par une balle par une bombe
par que sèche donc est ce que le fait de
se taire me donnerait beaucoup plus le
disons beaucoup plus de faire fierté non
je peux me regarder dans une glace et je
me sens totalement libre parce que
s'auto censurer et 10 ont évité de
parler par peur c'est en quelque sorte
faire une concession pour sa liberté moi
ma liberté j'y tiens donc je suis un
homme libre je veux rester un homme
libre je dis ce que je pense
et n'en déplaise celui qui n'est pas
content c'est la joue merci